-Is this a positive for you?
I mean, you grew up
in South Central.
You've seen this your whole
life, as you've mentioned.
Now there are people from all
different walks of life
who are addressing this issue,
at least saying they care about
this issue and want solutions.
Is that important to you?
Have you seen this before,
and are you hopeful that it will
be different this time?
-I mean, let's be honest.
I am so happy finally
that people are seeing
both sides of the coin
and that they're out there
marching and protesting.
And that's great.
That's great.
But there needs to be
more effective change made.
There needs to be more done.
And I'm grateful and thankful
that people see what we are
going through over here
and they have understanding
and they're like
"This has to stop."
I'm so grateful.
I'm grateful and thankful.
But you all need to be making
these phone calls
to these politicians,
to these board supervisors
and the mayor
and the councilmen.
There needs to be change made,
and there needs to be
an effective way
of dismantling the system
of oppression,
the syst-- systemic --
You know what I'm saying!
The racism has been
going on for a long time!
-[ Laughs ]
-It needs to be stopped.
-Hey, you and I are obviously --
we're in show business.
I have seen so many cop movies,
cop shows over the years.
I would call myself a fan
of those kind of shows.
And yet I realize
as we go through this,
so many of the cops
that are framed as heroes
often make choices that
require them crossing a line.
Because we see it from their
perspective, we think,
"Well, they know the right time
to cross the line."
Do you worry that the way
police are perceived
and growing up like you did
in South Central...
[ Dog barking ]
...was that something
that was always strange to you?
-I'm sorry, hold up.
I'm sorry.
There is a man at my door.
And my guard dog, the Maltese,
is losing it.
That's my little white dog.
She protects me. Hold up.
-[ Laughs ]
[ Door opens ]
-Thank you.
[ Door closes ]
Sorry, Seth.
-That's alright, Tiffany.
-I'm sorry, but the dog
would've barked the whole time
until I answered the door.
-How -- Now,
I'm not a dog expert,
but based on the bark,
that's not a large dog.
-No. She's like 7 pounds.
Sleeper!
This is my baby girl right here.
-[ Laughs ]
She's like,
"I'm not working right now.
Nobody's ringing the doorbell.
I'm not coming over there."
-She didn't get
her hair and makeup.
She didn't get her blowout.
-She's a little
Maltese Yorkie mix,
and she's my white guard dog.
She protects me.
-Do you feel that there
is a dangerous element
to how police are portrayed
on television and in films?
-I think that, you know,
I wish it was more truthful.
There are some movies that
are very true.
Like, I feel like "Training Day"
was like right on the money.
See, I've dated many
police officers
thinking I would be protected
and be safe that way.
Turns out no.
Turns out mnh-mnh,
mnh-mnh, no.
But lesson learned.
You know, you live, you learn.
And, you know,
Hollywood is Hollywood.
They're telling stories.
And there's not always truth
in those stories.
And I'm sure there's, like,
bits and tidbits of truth.
And I feel like --
I remember when I wanted to
be a police officer.
-Sure.
-And then I --
I remember being 7, 8 years old,
like "I wanna be a police!"
'Cause, you know, TV portrays
them as upright citizens
that, you know, they're here
to protect and keep the peace.
And then as I get older,
as I'm outside more,
especially when I went
into foster care,
it's not that.
It's not that.
I see them antagonizing,
creating drama amongst people.
I was talking to my friend
the other day.
She's like, "Well, why do y'all
keep killing each other?
If you guys didn't
kill each other --"
Girl, if you don't shu--
I was like,
"If you don't shut up..."
First of all, let's break down
why people kill each other.
And don't sit up here and act
like white people
don't kill each other,
'cause there is a whole channel
called the ID channel
that I can sit and watch
all day,
white people killing each other.
And never will there be
a rerun.
They show different
new murders every day.
But you watch the news
for 30 minutes
and think we over here
slaughtering each other.
And if that's the case, we would
all be gone, wouldn't we?